Guten Morgen Thomas.
Guten Morgen Tim.
In Deutschland ist gerade wieder die selbst Zerlegung in voller Fahrt.
Verkehrszeichen Österreich ist es besser lass uns lieber nach Brüssel schon.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 240 vom 22 Januar 2018 und ja wieder einmal begrüße ich Thomas hier als Verstärkung.
Und wir hatten ja auch schon nicht mal angedeutet sind gib den weg ja auch schon beschritten wollen wir mal solange Linus nicht dabei ist auch ein paar europäische Themen mal weiter vertiefen und heute haben uns noch weitere Verstärkung dazugeholt wir begrüßen den Joe,
Joe mcnamee.
Hallo.
Hallo du bist von der E3.
Über die wir hier schon immer viel besprochen haben immer mal wieder ein bisschen aber vielleicht kannst du ja mal die dreamer mit so deinen Worten vorstellen du bist ja der was dann deine offizielle Bezeichnung.
Auf Deutsch denke ich dass es ist Geschäftsführer heißt executive director.
Okay sind doch super.
Finde ich auch.
Was macht ihr.
Was wir machen sollte ist ein Verband von digitaler Bürgerrechts Verbänden aus ganz Europa und soviel versuchen zu die Arbeit des Verbandes zumachen zu Kontakte,
Zusammenarbeit zu bauen zwischen unseren Mitgliedern.
Information an den Mitgliedern zu schicken zur Systemen gibt es ist sehr wichtig dass die Verbände.
DaB sunshine in the sky oder digitale Gesellschaft in Deutschland dass die wissen was in Brüssel passiert,
sodass sie auf national national Ebenen auch aktiv werden können so versuchen so die Arbeit vor uns,
Mitglieder zu machen zur mit Inflation und so weiter und dann wird versuchen dann in Brüssel aber auch aktiv zu werden indem der zu treffen gehen und Konzentration.
Antworten und so so viel möglich in Brüssel die unsere Mitglieder zu vertreten und digitale Bürgerrechte zu verteidigen.
Ja das ist schon noch eine Untertreibung also weil was ich drin macht ist in ganz vielen der Themen nicht nur die Augen und,
Wanda Zivilgesellschaft zu sein also oft würde man es gar nicht mitbekommen was in Brüssel debattiert wird wenn sie drin ich gebe aber ihr habt ja auch ein sehr aktives Lobbying Büro und seid extrem gut da drinnen die die Interessen der Bürgerrechtsbewegung zu vertreten also full disclosure AOK mal mein Chef als,
Zeit wo ich für IT gearbeitet habe und ich habe sehr viel von ihm gelernt was Interessensvertretung angeht und wie immer,
wirklich macht an zu vielleicht kannst du auch mal ein Bild was zu dir sagen.
Du bist jetzt schon einige Jahre bei ydre ydre hat doch gerade seinen 15 Geburtstag den ist dieses Jahr glaube ich feiert was ist denn deine Geschichte und so die Geschichte von E3.
So die Geschichte von Edeka ist so vor ungefähr 15 Jahren haben ich denke 10 Verbände sich getroffen in Berlin haben gesagt dass es mir und wer der Gesetzgeber.
Erinnern an Termin aus.
Und dem gesagt dass das geht nicht mehr nur in den Mitgliedstaaten wir müssen irgendetwas bauen an der Beiz europäisch zu machen.
An das hatten sie dann vor 15 Jahren gemacht.
Ein bis 2009 hat es kein Impressum gegeben und ich habe dann in 2009 das bussloo buero geöffnet.
Am Anfang war ich alleine.
Und in den letzten 80 Jahren haben wir das Büro langsam aufgebaut und jetzt haben wir,
drei Solisten die.
Die sogenannte Lobbyarbeit machen Aktivisten Arbeit das ist keine echte Lobbyarbeit würde ich sagen dann haben wir eine Person die die Zeugnisse macht.
Eine Person die Indikation macht so die z.b. die Entwicklung von Tieren und die Internetseite tamsublock.
Macht man deinen für versuchen zurzeit haben wir solche Leute im buero umso diese zwei verschiedene,
Aufgaben zu machen auf einer Seite die Aktivisten arbeit mit der EU auf der anderen Seite die Informationen für das breite Publikum und die Teammitglieder.
Das ist beachtlich so innerhalb von 8 hat Jana von einem auf 11 Mitarbeiter und,
das was man vielleicht auch noch dazu sagen sollte dieses Treffen 2003 mit Dimitri gegründet wurde es wenn ich richtig liege auch am in BTC passiert.
Bei einem CCC Congress.
Ja da war ich aber nicht dabei.
Wie wirst du denn wie bist du denn dazu gekommen also was ist denn dein Hintergrund dass du jetzt Beiträge landet bist.
Ich habe 95/96 bei Compuserve.
Arbeitet so ein Internetanbieter nicht neu neutraler allem Internetanbieter.
In Großbritannien Arbeit erstens als Kundendienst und dann im technischen Dienst.
Dann bin ich nach Brüssel gekommen und ich habe.
Ein paar Monate vor einer Firma gearbeitet als Praktikant.
Dann habe ich einen Büro aufgemacht für eine britische Lobby Firma die und rangegangen.
Das Enten schnattern wie Anbieter Verband vertreten hat und vertritt immer noch so ich habe zwischen 98 und 2009.
Putty Internetanbieter the Furious bearbeitet.
Die vertritt meistens die kleineren Firmen einen 2009 hatte ich so genug davon.
Ich habe das das ist eine ganz zurück ganz komische komischer Zufall ich habe.
Ein Gespräch gehabt mit open society Foundation und die haben gesagt dass sie Interesse hätten digitale Bürgerrechte in Brüssel zu unterstützen.
Und ich kannte echt hatte damals einen sehr guten Ruf weil sie haben sehr gute Leute zu treffen und was zugeschickt.
Das Etui come-on.de Newsletter Fahrer und ist immer noch.
Sehr beliebt in Brüssel ich habe so gleichzeitig.
Gespräche gehabt mit Etrian mit open society und ich habe Unterstützung für ein Jahr bekommen.
Und das war genug um das Büro zu öffnen und dann der ein bisschen Schwung in die Bewegung in die Bürgerrechtsbewegung in Brüssel zu bringen.
Und dann wie gesagt wir sind dann gewachsen bis zu bis zu 2018.
Na das ist der erste Mitarbeiter von Ikea doch gleich sein eigenes funding mitgebracht und das XT3 hatte damals einen guten Ruf der ist heute noch mal viel stärker sich habe das selber überlebt wenn man,
hast du von einer kleinen Organisation aus E-Mails an irgendwelche Situationen schreibt wird man gerne mal ignoriert aber sobald ich meine ID Adresse hatte öffnen sich die Türen weil das ernst genommen wird und weil man damit ganz anderes Auftreten,
da ist es auf jeden Fall eigentlich mit mit Abstand von Access Europe,
DIY,
natürlich noch bis auf der Fondation Europe und andere die sich um Teilaspekte kümmern aber ihr habt ja ein riesiges Portfolio sehr kümmert euch ja um von von Datenschutz Urheberrecht Netzwerk alität,
nicht der gesamte netzpolitische Reigen und und so Fernseher Kapazitäten zulassen versucht hier überall mitzuspielen.
Ja das ist das ist das dein Problem soll es ist es gibt mehr und jedes Jahr gibt es mehr zu tun als das Jahr zuvor und Ethik,
sein gut weil wir alles sehr präzise und korrekt und also expert,
machen ohne irgendwelche Fehler zu machen und wenn wir zwei Themen haben ist es relativ einfach sind S3 ist ist es ein bisschen schwerer zur Zeit haben wir so viele verschiedene,
Themen des dass die Dieselqualität immerzu zu respektieren ist.
Ist schwer aber wir bis jetzt haben wir das geschafft.
Welcher mal kurz nachfragen darf was was ist denn so der Grund für den guten Ruf habt ihr da irgendwie eine andere Herangehensweise als das jetzt andere Organisation andere Lobbyorganisation machen mach dir irgendwas ganz anders.
So es gibt so arbeitet das was ich jetzt tue ist nicht.
Lobbyismus deswegen weil wenn man ein Lobbyist ist hat man.
Denkt man an die kurzfristige Proleten von einer Firma oder eine Branche.
Wenn man Aktivist ist hat man Prinzipien die dauerhaft sind.
Deswegen hat man eine andere Sicht und mehr wir können.
Besser auf Dauer und Anneliese behaupten zur für Lobbyisten sie eines eine ein Jahr und dann müssen sie etwas anderes denken das nächste Jahr.
Ja
Und zwar erstens das ein an versenden wenn Sie an einen Politiker sind und jemand.
Prinzipien grundsätzlich und dauerhaft verteidigt dann weiß man mitnehmen mit wem man spricht und was man von dem warten kann.
Und das heißt dass man sich auf unsere Anneliese Wasser verlassen kann.
Zweitens wir sind ein bisschen langweilig so unsere Anneliese ist nicht sehr wir schreien nicht.
Wir machen sehr präzise Dokumente die erklären warum.
Etwas gegen unsere Rechte stoßt oder und rechte unterstützen und das tun wir in der Sprache der Union.
Das ist nicht aufregend das ist nur das Etui ist die Leute die bequem und präzise.
Sich erklärt wann das notwendig ist und das finden Politiker nützlich.
Arm das zweite ist dass wir wir versuchen sehr früh in jedem Gespräch zu sein das heißt dass dir von Anfang bis Ende.
Und diese dauerhafte Unterstützung finden Politiker auch nützlich.
Z.b. mit der Datenschutzverordnung für waren da bevor die Kommission die Kommunikation zwischen die Stadt wir waren da als die das Parlament.
Dekoration besprochen hat.
Bevor die Verordnung veröffentlicht wurde und die ganze sechs Jahre der Rand des des Gesetzgebungsprozess ist.
Und zu wissen das Etui da ist dass man uns vertrauen kann.
Das dauert das das ist etwas wert vor dir zu to Zion das heißt leider auch dass man uns sehr wenig in die in die Nachrichten hören uns nicht.
Schreien hören meistens dass etwas ganz Schlimmes passiert wir versuchen so viel möglich so leise möglich zu zu schaffen was bisher uns relativ gut,
klingt.
Das ist sowieso ein Problem Zoe 3 hat schon eine Stimme die gehört wird innerhalb der bubble,
der europäischen Gesetzgebung Bubble aber aus dieser Babel hinaus zu kommunizieren ist sehr schwierig vor allem auch weil,
die innenpolitischen Redaktionen über Europa meistens nur dann berichten wenn die Abstimmung schon passiert ist.
Nicht im Vorfeld wenn die Leute noch was tun könnten um das ganze zu beeinflussen aber das ist eigentlich auch eine gute Überleitung zu unserem ersten Thema,
ein Thema das in Deutschland ja gerade wieder große Wellen schlägt im Rahmen des netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetzes aber was du ja glaube ich auch schon seit vielen vielen Jahren als eines deiner Spezialthemen hast unter dem etwas breiteren Begriff plattformregulierung,
und vielleicht können wir da mal einsteigen ist unser klärst worum geht's im Grunde plattformregulierung wir wissen ja dass das netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz mit sehr viel mit Optifine diese hate speech Debatte aber vielleicht Unterricht mit der Fake News Debatte begründet wurde und man hier sozusagen,
Formen in die Pflicht nehmen wollte an das ganze hat ja eine Geschichte kannst du uns erklären wie die aussieht.
Die Geschichte ist unglaublich lang und wir haben unglaublich wenig geschafft so für mich.
Fängt die Geschichte an N97 in Deutschland.
So der Geschäftsführer von copies of mein ehemaliger.
Arbeitgeber wurde verhaftet weil vermutlich illegale Inhalte auf den Servern von combisafe gefunden wurden.
Und man hat sich gefragt was tut man überhaupt mit dem Internet wenn es ganz überschreiten bist wenn es illegale Inhalte gibt.
21 Jahre später haben wir anscheinend absolut hat ganz und gar nichts gelernt.
Und haben wir wir haben in den 2018 so ungefähr.
Dieser dieser Button die wir in 97 gehabt haben.
Inzwischen gibt es soll es gibt sehr illegalen Inhalte wie Kinderpornografie und auch so Hassreden und.
Suche Rechtsverletzungen alle mögliche und Politiker wissen nicht was die Antwort ist.
Und deswegen wie Homer Simpson das einmal gesagt hat jemand anderes sollte sich damit beschäftigen jemand anderes sind die Plattform.
Egal was das Problem ist jetzt heutzutage die Antwort ist dass diese magische Internetplattform alles perfekt verhältnismässig regeln können.
Aber es gibt ja wir haben ja schon teilweise so Lösung gefunden es gibt Jan Hus providerprivileg im EU Gesetz so der Kommas Richtlinie und das sagt ja schon eigentlich dass man erst dann Haft,
was ist wenn man Kenntnis erlangt von augenscheinlich illegalen Inhalten auf der eigenen Plattform,
alter wieso reicht das nicht das wieso haben wir das was wir damals in dem gesetzlich festgeschrieben haben wieso debattieren wir heute wieder drum.
So das ist ich denke dass dass das Beste was Europa in Internet Erklärung gemacht hat ist diese E-Commerce-Richtlinie.
Aber der ist ständig unter Angriff gewesen seid.
Redaktion der Erklärung so man sagt dass das.
Dass sie zu langsam erklären dass sie nicht gut genug ergeben dass es jetzt Algorithmen gibt wo Inhalte können bevor sie überhaupt auf dem Internet erscheinen,
und ja so wie gesagt die.
Die Technologie kann alle Probleme lösen und jetzt verstecken sich die Plattform hinter dieser Richtlinie und das ist inakzeptabel und.
Es gibt schlimme Dinge und deswegen müssen wir was tun und deswegen in allen möglichen Bereichen.
Sagen die Politiker dass die Plattform mehr mehr irgendetwas mehr eben eben wie schneller irgendetwas erreichen müssen.
Gehen wir mal ins Detail also was konkret wird von den Plattformen gefordert.
Mehr Inhalte schneller besser löschen bevor diese Inhalte überhaupt auf das Internet auf dem Internet löschen.
Und vielleicht noch mal aktuelles ist er so dass der Provider seine Nutzung mal machen lassen kann und nicht in der Haftung ist also er ist wieder.
Wenn wenn der Nutzer was illegales macht ist der Plattformbetreiber nicht gleichzeitig auch schuldig an diesen potenziellen Verbrechen aber der hat auch keine,
Second Life LEDs er ist auch dadurch dass es nicht verhindert hat nicht in der Haftung das ist der Status Quo und von Demon will man weggehen das eigentlich schon bevor etwas erscheinen darf bist du etwas veröffentlicht wird muss der Plattformbetreiber eigentlich schon,
tätig werden ansonsten drohen ihm Haftungsfragen.
Ja so ist es gibt ja es gibt gleich es gibt verschiedene Initiativen gleichzeitig auf welchen Ebenen des CD,
alle schlimmste ist die Richtlinie und die versucht.
Angeblich ohne die E-Commerce-Richtlinie ohne die aktuelle Gesetzgebung zu ändern versucht versucht die Kommission gleichzeitig Haftung für.
Die illegale Inhalte zu etablieren für die Provider,
surfing the palm reliable süße primär und auch Haftung dafür dass sie nichts dagegen geschafft der gemacht haben so sie sind.
Frankfurt Licht für die Inhalte und verantwortlich dafür dass sie nicht genug gemacht haben ging die Inhalte.
An das ist wie gesagt angeblich ohne die Gelenke zu ändern.
Das würde heißen dass die die Performance sehr viel mehr sehr viel schneller,
löschen müssten um nicht für die Reinhard zu haften.
Das heißt er Upload Filter downloadfilter soviel zu löschen dass das Risiko minimiert werden könnte.
So das ist die E-Commerce-Richtlinie es gibt auch die audiovisuelle Mediendienste Richtlinie.
Die normale medienzoo.
Sender TV Fernseh und Radiosender und jetzt neulich auch soziale Medien aber nur im Bezug auf auf Video.
Und da werden sie haften dafür würden sie würden für illegale Inhalte haften Haftung für Inhalte die vielleicht illegal sind.
Und sie werden auch verantwortlich verantwortlich für die sittliche Entwicklung von Minderjährigen was etwas.
Ganz erstaunliches ist.
Aber das mal konkret machen also das wird z.b. wenn ich meinen YouTube Kanal habe oder wenn ich Vimeo bin wenn ich irgendeinen Medienkanal betreibe fahre ich,
auf einmal unter dieselbe Regelung die Moment nur für Fernsehsender gilt und muss mich auch daran den Anforderungen orientieren die man eigentlich eben nur für ein ganzes Handy Netzwerk,
also dass das auf einmal eben auch für.
Von der mit Joseph United Content gilt und und ich auch sozusagen schon vorab alle Inhalte die erscheinen bei mir.
Kontrollieren was doch eigentlich bei dem Youtube-Kanal aber nicht so das Problem ist oder.
Ja so ist das nicht ganz dasselbe aber ähnliche Erklärung und dass das ist auch eine Richtlinie und keine Verordnung,
das heißt dass wenn diese Richtlinie verabschiedet wird müssen die 27 Mitgliedsländer.
Diese Richtlinie in 27 Gesetze umsetzen.
Ein ich denke auf in Deutschland ist das auf Land Ebene implementiert um das.
Noch ein bisschen kompliziert zu machen und dann als Internetplattform müssen Sie entweder.
Eine Wicklung machen für für jedes Land jedes Mitgliedstaat in Europa.
Oder einfach die schlimmste Regelung von dem Schlimmsten Mitgliedsland nehmen,
wann denn dieser für ganz Europa umsetzen damit sie zumindestens ein bisschen Klarheit schaffen können.
Vielleicht um ein Schritt zurück also wir waren voll noch bei Compuserve 19.97,
und da wurde irgendwie der Geschäftsführer vom Internet Provider verhaftet weil,
legaler inhalt auf den Servern war solche Geschichten kennt man ja aus den Neunzigern werden in Österreich Ausfall von Internet Provider von der Polizei gesucht wird und alle Server von mitgenommen weil da ein illegal inhalt gab und dann hatten wir diese,
hatte in den Neunzigern die David 2001 zur ich komme als Richtlinie geführt hat in diesem Haus providerprivileg,
da haben wir doch was gelernt dann wir doch eigentlich irgendwie hat die Politik doch irgendwie erkannte das mit dem Internet funktioniert nur wenn man dem Leine gibt wenn man jetzt nicht vorab kontrolliert was Nutzer.
Online auf Plattform hochladen und vor allem der Betreiber der Plattform kann nicht diese Vorabkontrolle machen.
Wieso sind wir davon soweit weg gekommen dass wir heute sagen müssen Hey nein du musst da vorab jede Art von Kontrolle machen weil wir wir haben so ein großes Problem im Internet da hat sich doch,
grundlegend was an der Tipp,
hatte verschoben an wahrscheinlich denken die Politiker heute auch nicht mein Elternhaus Provider sondern nur noch an Facebook und Google.
Was hat die Dahlener Debatte verschoben.
So entsetzlich geht es,
alles immer um Recht so es seit 2001 hatte sich ständig Lobbyarbeit gegen diese E-Commerce-Richtlinie gegeben,
das würde immer wieder versucht vor Gericht die Wirkung von der Richtlinie zu minimieren.
Und bis neulich,
mit Tourismus Meta Skaten mit andere Probleme haben sie versucht zu diese Richtlinie zu zu löschen schließlich,
und dass das kommt auch.
Und es ist interessant zu sehen dass wir haben wir haben eine Kinderschutz Richtlinie wo.
Keine Pflichten entstehen für die Anbieter sie haben eine Terrorismus Richtlinie wo,
keine neue Pflichten entstehen für die Anbieter und wir haben eine neue Copyright liegt in Richtlinie wo.
Doch neue pflichte und z.b. diese Option für diese neue Frankfurter besteht.
Ant man muss sich die Frage stellen warum ist Urheberrecht so viel schlimmer und so viel wichtiger als erstes muss.
Schauspieler Gehalt in in Brüssel zurzeit.
Ja ich glaube das ist ja auch in den USA so also der beste Weg etwas aus dem Internet in den USA zu bekommen ist eine imce Anfrage also eine an,
Kickdown versucht wegen Urheberrecht zu machen und die meisten solcher anfragen passieren auch ohne dass es wirklich einen unberechtigten Rechtsanspruch gibt.
Das ist einfach der effizienteste Weg Dinge aus dem Internet zu zensieren,
da ist die die Lobby aus der Ecke wahrscheinlich einfach am stärksten aber gerade bei der ganzen Fake News und hate speech Debatte da geht's ja doch dann noch um andere.
Themenbereich weil das die obere Industrie und wie gerne Netzsperren hätte dass es nichts Neues aber da geht ja wirklich auch um.
Diese Frage der Verantwortung der Plattformen und ich glaube das ist auch noch ein ganz unwichtiger Bereich über den wir sprechen müssen wo wo sozusagen man versucht.
Jan Kunde Rechtsdurchsetzung Rechtsprechung zu privatisieren.
Und uns wäre eigentlich aus der Pflicht genommen wird nämlich die Strafverfolgungsbehörden.
Ja so so erstens denn wenn man verzehrend sein will und wenn man die Probleme echt richtig anfassen will dann muss man die.
Muss man die Dinge von Zeit von der Seite der Plattform stehen so sie haben Kunde Inhalte zu Liste löschen und wie konnte sie zu löschen.
Und was man versucht ist sie mehr und mehr Kunde zu geben Inhalte zu zu löschen.
Ob das in der Richtlinie in der Masse m = oder des Verhaltenskodex vom Husky.
Die weiter sind immer wieder dazu fast gezwungen die Inhalte zu löschen.
Vielleicht bringen wir das mal so eine konkreter zu machen.
Auf die Beispiel des deutschen netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz ist da ist ja jetzt in den letzten Wochen auch viel passiert hat das Gesetz in Kraft ist.
Und wir haben da jetzt schon einige Fälle wo das netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz wirklich so als rollwerkzeug verwendet,
wurde um unliebsame Stimmen von von allem auch linken Aktivisten,
aus dem Netz zu zensieren und da meine zwischen auch sehen kann dass Leute sich organisieren und einfach gezielt diese Möglichkeit eines notice Eis übers Netzwerk in contents,
aus dem Netz zu brennen genau da Fitness sozusagen einerseits das Gesetz bis braucht.
In dem Jahr überhaupt keine Kontrolle stattfindet also gerade Twitter ist hier sehr sonnig in der inhaltlichen.
Kontrolle und die Befürchtung ist aber das genau dieses deutsche Modell ähnlich wie auf dem Leistungsschutzrecht dann auf europäischer Ebene exportiert wird siehst du da irgendeine Gefahr dass die Kommission sich an Deutschland am Beispiel nimmt.
Ja nein so in der Gruppe gilt auch die kommt gleich ciao ciao.
Und wenn man ein Gesetz verabschieden will muss man relativ zufrieden sein dass wenn das vor Gericht geht.
Ist das kompatibel mit der mit der Kater.
Und wenn die Anbieter dazu gezwungen erzogen gebracht werden können wie z durch einen Verhaltenskodex.
Ist das kein Gesetz und dann muss man die Torte nicht mehr respektieren.
Deswegen so dick Mission ist nicht gerade überzeugt von dem Netz DG deswegen weil das ein Gesetz ist.
Und es kommt zu mit wenn man ein Gesetz verabschieden will.
Muss man das vor Gericht verteidigen und sie wollen viel lieber freiwillige sogenannte freiwillige Selbstkontrolle zwingen.
Ich habe das ist ein ganz zentraler Punkt also das netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz kann man höchstgerichtliche angreifen weil es ein Gesetz ist wo der Staat Inge vorschreibt die wahrscheinlich gegengrund,
Rechte verstoßen,
die Kommission ist aber sag bitte liebes Facebook Google kümmert euch mal um den Terrorismus dann gibt's da keine rechtliche Grundlage sondern eigentlich nur eine freiwillige Selbstverpflichtung gegen die Mahngericht,
überhaupt nicht vorgehen kann an dahintersteckt er noch was anderes weil wenn ein Provider aufgrund von,
eigenen Richtlinien oder community guidelines Ding gelöscht hat auch.
Der Betroffene Nutzer kann Grundrechtsschutz in irgendeiner Form zum Beispiel auf sein Recht auf Veröffentlichung oder Recht auf einen fairen Prozess wenn Inhalte gelöscht werden Zube,
was heißt hier verlieren wir auch auf der subjektiven Ebene an Rechten Didi bei großen Plattform ja natürlich ganz zentral sind weil wenn man da nicht vor,
komm auf dem Internet nicht mehr vor.
Ja das ist das zentrale Problem von Bürgerrechte im digitalen Zeitalter die Europäische Kommission und Mitgliedsländer.
Können Verfassungen und die Torte ganz einfach umgehen wenn Sie es schaffen die weiter dazu zu bringen das sogenannte freiwillig.
Zu tun und man sieht genau was du gerade gesagt hast im Verhaltenskodex zu Hassreden es steht ganz deutlich,
das dann eine Kacke kommt bei den Providern sie müssen erstens sehen,
ob das Gegenteil RGB stoßen stößt und nur dann.
Sehen ob das gegen das Gesetz stoßt so das Gesetz ist deutlich zweitrangig in diesem Kodex.
Und das ist wie gesagt, um die Karte zu umgehen an das ist das ist sehr schlimm.
Steht in diesem Kodex an ich auch irgendetwas drinnen dass man illegale Inhalte an die Strafverfolgungsbehörden melden soll.
Nein nein an ganz am Anfang des Gesprächs hat die Kommission mir gesagt das würde die Mitgliedstaaten nicht akzeptieren.
Wir können das nicht vorschlagen weil die Mitgliedstaaten der Gegenwehr.
Aber das bedeutet Kunde.
Der Staat will keine Gesetze machen weil die Windjacke und rechtswidrig die Provider sollen sich selbstständig drum kümmern auch wenn die Nutzer dann,
bei falscher Löschung und bei overblocking kein Rechtsbehelf mehr haben und die Strafverfolgungsbehörden wollen sich im Grunde gar nicht mit dem Thema beschäftigen weil das macht ja nur Aufwand und ganz viele Fälle,
abends zu heißt das soll einfach gelöscht werden ohne dass es geerntet wird wunderbar.
So jeder jeder Beteiligte ist damit einigermaßen zufrieden so die Plattform sind zufrieden weil sie die Dinge löschen aufgrund der AGBs.
Sie haben nie gesagt dass sie irgendetwas irgendwann gehustet hat was illegal ist.
Der Plattform ist einigermaßen damit zufrieden.
Da Mitgliedsstaat ist zufrieden weil sie keine Meldungen hat zum Thema illegale Inhalte.
Weil niemand hat gesagt dass es illegal war.
Derjenige der die illegale Inhalte aufs Internet gestellt hat ist zufrieden weil keiner hat gesagt dass es illegal war,
so alle außer gegen falsche Opfer und Meinungsfreiheit sind relativ zufrieden.
Bitte Finnisch.
Er am,
ich frage dieses Diermeier schon sehr lang aber wir werden hier auch noch auf viele der edle Artikel dazu verlinken und ich glaube das ist eine sehr aktive Debatte,
glaubst du das wird sich jetzt in dieser gesetzgebungsperiode noch noch weiter etwas tun also gibt's da Punkte wo Leute die Augen offen halten sollten und,
vielleicht noch aktiver im können zu dem Thema.
Das allerwichtigste aktiv zu werden ist die die Richtlinie.
Deswegen weil es die Richtlinie geht nicht um recht es gibt viele Leute die sagen ja das ist sehr interessant aber,
was geht was geht mir diese Erbrecht an es geht um primäre und sekundäre Haftung von Providern an das wird dann Wirkung haben für alle Inhalte,
es geht um Upload Filter es geht um zu wählen von allem was man.
Den hat sogar opera config.
Könnte ich dieses Wort vergessen Überwachung von alle allem was man auf Internet hochladen will.
Wichtiger kann das nicht sein und wie gesagt es ist nicht nur es geht nicht um.
Du kannst es geht um Überwachung von alles was wir Erfinder tun außer so es gibt jetzt diese Heiler betrug zum Thema Fake News.
Die Kommission will irgendetwas tun vor der vor dem Sommer was das sein könnte ist mehr.
Ist allem relativ deutlich das könnte nicht sehr gut sein ich nehme an dass dick Mission.
Sagen wir dass die Tasche etwas freiwillig ist anzunehmen müssten egal was das Problem ist das ist immer die Lösung wenn das Fett höchstwahrscheinlich auch hier die Lösung angeblich sein.
Ja groß ist die man an.
Wann der Stelle nochmal verwiesen auf die letzte Folge mit Julia Rehder wo wir uns eh noch mal näher mit der Bericht Richtlinie und den Upload filtern da drinnen beschäftigt haben auch mit dem Möglichkeiten bei dem das hier konkret aktiv zu werden.
Aber so du hast ja nicht mehr viel Zeit deswegen wollte ich vielleicht noch kurz zu einem anderen Thema kommen nämlich die e-privacy Verordnung.
Was hatten wir auch noch kurz sprechen wenn wir das glaube ich bis jetzt noch nicht wirklich behandelt haben hier im Podcast kannst du dazu vielleicht kurz noch was sagen also das ist ja sozusagen die haben.
Nach der datenschutzgrundverordnung die im Mai diesen Jahres 2018,
Kraft treten wird macht man jetzt noch mal ein zweites Gesetz zum Datenschutz auf EU-Ebene,
und was man ja von manchen Lobbyisten hört ist wozu brauchen wir das denn die datenschutz-grundverordnung reicht doch schon an wieso brauchen wir noch eine e-privacy-verordnung.
Der soll ich habe in den letzten sieben Jahren habe ich die Lobbyistin hören sagen dass die kommt gleich kommt.
Datenschutz wadenlang das allerschlimmste der ganzen Welt ist und jetzt ist das perfekt und brauchen wir nichts anderes,
f*** dich am Anfang gesagt habe die Lobbyisten hatten Tendenz eines zu sagen und dann etwas ganz anderes zu sagen,
der folgenden Debatte es geht um die Vertraulichkeit freundlicher Zion es geht um die Inhalte von E-Mails von anrufen es geht über Verschlüsselung.
Der Vorratsdatenspeicherung es geht um wie und ob man gefolgt werden kann durch,
Raiffeisen als Mann in einem Beispiel jetzt schon in Flughafen in Amsterdam als Mann durch den Flughafen,
aber Mut die WiFi-Netzwerk.
Ford wo du bist wie lange du da bist in welchen Geschäften zu du gehst wie lange du im Geschäft bist ist das.
Erlaubt oder nicht soll das erlaubt werden oder nicht in welchen Fällen soll das erlaubt werden so online und offline so gestalkt werden ob das klappt Kabel ist toll oder nicht,
Opti Provider die Inhalte.
Deinem Haus oder deine Anrufer benutzen können für gewerbliche Zwecke.
Es ist da es ist anderes es ist nichts.
Einfach Datenschutz es geht auch so wie gesagt er Vertraulichkeit von persönlichen und geschäftlichen Gespräch annikazion.
Das ganze war vorhin richtig das wird jetzt eine Verordnung dieses Gesetz hat schon das Europaparlament passiert und ist jetzt schon im Trilog.
Was heißt denn das also in welchem Status ist dieses Gesetz jetzt gerade.
Das ist nicht ganz entrelac ist es halbwegs in Trilog das Parlament hat einen text,
dass das Parlament bereitest in Trilog,
zu verteidigen die Industrie hat eine riesige Lobbyarbeit auf nationaler Ebene gemacht um die Mitgliedstaaten gegen,
die,
in Brüssel haben wir so lange Zeit viel Arbeit gemacht,
zum Thema Datenschutz und Vertraulichkeit von annikazion leider sind wir nicht in den Mitgliedsländern und Emden deswegen haben die Industrie,
versucht die ihre Lobbyarbeit anderswo zu machen und die Mitgliedstaaten imgart sind dabei ihre,
pfändungs Position zu finanzieren um dieses Trelock anzufangen.
Also anstatt eine richtige,
transparente Diskussion zu haben zwischen den Institutionen wir haben so ein System namens Trelock,
na das heißt dass das Parlament und der Rat nimmt eine Position und dann,
haben Sie geheime Gespräche bis zu sie einen text haben wo wo alle Leute sich einigen voraus alle sich einigen können.
Und wir warten wie gesagt auf dem Rad.
Ja das ist das lustige eigentlich haben wir in EU Gesetzgebungsverfahren und dann gibt es den Trilog der nirgends festgeschrieben ist und komplett intransparent passiert.
Aber noch mal warum warum wir das hier gestritten also man hat ja schon gehört das zur wir uns einige gute Sachen erhoffen wie z.b. dass du Nord,
rechtlich verpflichtend wird also die Möglichkeit schon in meinem Browser oder auf meinem Gerät zu sagen das geht dass ich eigentlich nicht gecheckt werden will oder sowas wie ein Werbe und,
wecker Blocker der dann auch respektiert werden muss von dem Seite,
Betreiber da macht ja die Werbeindustrie ganz massiv Sturm dagegen und beraubt,
wenn diese e-privacy-verordnung so kommt dann stirbt die Demokratie weil dann stirbt die Online-Werbung und damit sterben ja auch die Zeitungen,
anders sind so ernsthafte Argumentationen die man in dem Bereich hört die natürlich darauf beruhen dass das derzeitige Werbegeschäft Modell ganz stark auf der Hut der kommerziellen Überwachung von beiden Völkern Geschichten passiert,
hattest du nicht wollen dass es da effiziente Schutzmechanismen,
dass man eben auch im Internet unterwegs ist ohne überall verfolgt oder wie du schon gesagt hast gestalkt zu werden dass das ist so ein Thema und dann das überwachungszimmer das wird mich noch interessieren was von Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Ich brauche das was genau heißt das es soll ja hier auch messenger-dienst Derivat.
Opernsänger Sonja auch betroffen sein von dieser Verordnung.
Ankunft wofür wir eine neue Wohnung brauchen ist das bis jetzt war nur die Telekom Dienste.
Von der jetzigen Richtlinie betroffen und es ist ganz deutlich dass die Messenger Dienste und so weiter dieselben Regeln respektieren müssten.
Das heißt dass eine breitere Liste von Diensten betroffen wird von der neuen Verordnung als die alte.
Richtlinie es gibt dann ein Artikel 11 die Ausnahme Artikel und darin steht was.
Nicht betroffen wird von von der Richtlinie und in 2002 als I Richtlinie.
Adoptiert wurde hat Großbritannien Namenstag Vereinigten Staaten gefragt das in Artikel in dem Artikel.
Soll man sagen dass Furz Datenspeicherung nicht verboten werden müsste.
Durch die Frauen durch die durch die Richtlinie und das haben sie auch geschafft.
Und jetzt wollen die Mitgliedstaaten schon wieder irgendeine Art von Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Und sie versuchen erneut Vorratsdatenspeicherung durch die Hintertür von dieser von diesem diese Forderung zu hinzu.
Kreieren.
Und das obwohl wir schon zweimal vom Arabischen ins Gericht bestätigt bekommen haben dass eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung und rechtswidrig ist es ist wirklich.
Ja schade wenn das immer noch probiert wird und wenn uns doch um zum Thema schreiben müssen.
Ja es wird langsam Zeit dass das dieses Gespräch zu Ende kommt aber,
irgendwie die Socken Gespräche haben kommen immer wieder wenn die richtige Antwort nicht da nicht kommt Fragen werden dann zweites Mal und ein drittes Mal.
Ja am wir verlinken auch hier ist Kapern 34 C3 ein interessanten Talk von Ingo dachwitz über die privacy Verordnung.
Unterschied Reh und auch nicht fertig haben zu dem Thema auch einige Sachen schon publiziert.
Ja jo haben wir noch irgendwelche Themen vergessen wo du sagst das ist jetzt auch noch auf der Agenda im Mai 2019 sind ja Europawahlen und da.
Bitte noch einiges passieren bis dahin nämlich an gibt's noch andere Themen die du vielleicht kurz erwähnen Wer ist an denen ihr arbeitet oder die dich wach halten am Abend.
Es gibt eine ganz komische Linie die eigentlich Mittwoch diese Woche veröffentlicht werden müsste von der Kommission und kommt jetzt.
Nächsten Monat es ist eine Richtlinie um Zugriff zu weiß Daten.
Alles geht darum ob die Strafverfolgungsbehörden in einem Land direkt Daten an Provider in einem anderen Mitgliedsland fragen.
Durften oder könnten einen in welchen Fällen das möglich wäre und das ist.
Das wird sehr heiß schnell weil die Kommission will auch dass diese Regeln auch für Drittländer gelten könnten.
Handgeländer könnte auch die Vereinigten Staaten heißen und auch andere Länder der Welt.
Also es geht um am Transparenz und Informationen an den Nutzer um die ganze Welt und ob das den falschen Fall,
alles geht auch komischerweise um Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Weil weil denn wenn es ein Gesetz gibt dass die Behörden in einem Land.
Daten in einem anderen Land direkt an den Provider fragen darf dann muss muss alle Leute wissen.
Wie lange diese Daten bestehen und die beste Möglichkeit zu wissen ob diese Daten existieren oder nicht.
Ist eine Regel zu haben dass die Daten sechs Monate oder einem Jahr gespeichert werden sollen.
Als ob man eine Richtlinie zu internationalen Datenzugriff haben kann.
Unna.
Und unter uns eine Frage.
Und dann packt dann werden wir zum betreff.
Joy unter welchem Namen läuft in dieser Initiative mit den Beweis Daten.
Es soll auf Englisch heißt das direkte von Crossbow Traxxas Capitals so Richtlinie über Kürbissuppe.
Grenzübergreifende Beweis Daten Kempten.
Ja also ich weiß das da in der in der Icepeak Community schon lange darüber gestritten wird weil das heißt natürlich konkret zu machen wenn die ungarischen Behörden von einem deutschen Onlinedienste,
haben haben wollen dann müssen Sie bei der deutschen Polizei Polizei Anfragen und dann nochmals Rechtshilfeersuchen stellen,
und dann kriegen sie die Daten eigentlich auch nur wenn das nicht darf.
Das ist ja auch nach deutschen Recht eine beauskunftung rechtfertigen würde und genau das will man abschaffen dass du eigentlich so lang,
irgendwo eine Rechtsgrundlage gibt auch in anderen Ländern den Zucker fahren kannst und das eben nicht nur auf EU Länder begrenzen vielleicht sogar auch von,
außer europäischen Ländern und eben noch dazu die Frage ja wenn ich da Daten beauskunften kann.
Müssen die vielleicht sogar extra länger vorgehalten werden was natürlich dann eine Speicherfrist bedeuten könnte und vielleicht eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
über die Hintertür ist es auch jetzt mal so wenn ich jo an die kostbar directive richtig verstanden habe zusammengefasst.
Ich denke das war das war eine ganz tolle Zusammenfassung das wird so kompliziert sind die europäische die Artikel des Vertrags.
Wo kauft man eine solche Richtlinie Version könnte ist auch nicht deutlich,
und es ist so kompliziert rechtlich gesehen so kompliziert dass ich heute früh gehört habe dass sie vielleicht zwei verloren haben könnten,
einer für die in arabische fragen und dann eine andere für die Zusammenarbeit mit Drittländern.
Und weil das halt so wichtig und plötzlich so dringend wird versuchen das nächstes Monat zu verabschieden von der Kommission.
Wann dass er zwei Doktoren vor der Wahl in mein erstes Jahr.
Also ich weiß dass Europol hier massiven Druck machte noch in dieser Legislaturperiode eine rechtliche Grundlage für den Bereich zu haben.
Fanta mich wundert nicht dass man das Ding gleich möglichst groß machen will das haben wir auch beim Urheberrecht gesehen wenn man gar nicht erst versucht irgendwie ein annehmbares grundrechtskonform es Gesetz vorzuschlagen sondern dass möglichst schlimm macht dann,
werden die Bürgerrechtler und in dem Fall auch die Internetprovider deren Interessen sich zum Teil damit unseren,
wecken nur noch damit beschäftigt sein die schlimmsten Dinge zu bekämpfen anstatt irgendwie saubere grundrechtskonforme Lösung zu bekommen die das vielleicht auf der Gericht hält.
Und anwenden das nicht kompliziert genug wäre gibt es eine ganz andere Initiative im Europarat in Straßburg um ein internationales Vertrag zum selben Thema.
Aber weltweit zu machen das heißt dass DU.
Und gleichzeitig dasselbe tun.
Ja also euch wird nicht langweilig.
Nein bei uns ist es nie langweilig.
RAID hat auch gerade wie ich sie einige job openings für intense ich ich kann das nicht jeden empfehlen wenn man die Möglichkeit hat bei E3 an zu zocken sollte man das Tunnel lernt man viel.
Hast du doch am.
Was sucht er denn für Leute.
Sag es ganz verschiedene Praktikantin da ist er Leute die sich echt.
Mit dem mit dem Thema Interessenvertretung digitale Bürgerrechte europäische Politik auseinandersetzen wollen dann sind Sie hier.
Richtig.
Leute die Leidenschaft die brennt muss man denn noch andere Voraussetzung haben außer Leidenschaft.
So intelligent ja auch nützlich so Leute die die einstudieren.
Machen oder gerade gemacht haben zum Thema auch welcher Politiker oder internationales Recht.
Hauptsache dass sie die Themen studiert haben oder studieren und wir wollen ist das sehr wichtig sonst das werden wir bald die Kanten haben dass sie etwas hier lernen.
Das heißt dass wenn wir einen eine Bewerbung bekommen wir wollen sehen dass sie irgendwohin wollen und sie zieht sie wollen lernen um etwas zu tun.
Nicht um ein Praktikum zu machen an sondern um etwas zu schaffen für sich selbst.
Weil es gibt viel zu viele Praktiken in Brüssel die kein Sinn haben und wir bezahlen auch ein bisschen weil das halt nur fair ist.
Ja so bevor man irgendwie das typische Kommissions Praktikum macht das ganz viele Leute machen und man eigentlich nur lernt wieso große bürokratischer Ansatz Ionen,
gefährlich und die motivieren sind sollte man lieber zu einer kleineren NGO gehen und da ist E3,
zu empfehlen ich habe auf der Webseite nachgeschaut es wird gerade nach einem communications & Community intern.
Gesucht und nach einem policy intern und beide stellen sind von März bis Juli ausgeschrieben Antalya wir verlinken die beiden auch.
Zu was kann man noch tun um ihre zu unterstützen ich glaube ihr freut euch über Spenden um zu Porter.
Ja sehr sauer Spenden sowieso und dann zur Porta die regelmäßig uns unterstützen,
noch mehr die Arbeit die gemacht werden muss für digitale Bürgerrechte.
Hört nicht auf zu großer zu werden das ist unglaublich und wir sind irgendwie wir werden großer und immer wieder.
Zu klein verpacken so viel Unterstützung möglich um diese Arbeit zu machen diese Arbeit die die man nicht besonders gut von von dem Mitgliedsstaaten aussehen aber.
Dieser wichtig ist und es ist auch uns sehr wichtig dass unsere Mitglieder stark,
sind an das heißt dass so viele Leute wie möglich sich bei euch Episode hokksund,
und kann uns andere Mitglieder tätig werden und euch auch unterstützen.
Hahn auf jeden Fall an und dann meine meine letzte Empfehlung für alle Leute die vielleicht.
Sich insgesamt mehr für für die europäische Politik eben interessieren weil man kann nur sagen da sind viele Themen die.
Dann später so oder so als vorhin oder Richtlinie auf die Mitgliedstaaten zu kommen und man muss sich mit Rüssel beschäftigen das ist so ein Bild wie das Internet wenn man es nicht,
dann beeinflusst ist das eigene Leben trotzdem und da gibt's noch eine Ressource die ich empfehlen will und zwar den Newsletter von Etretat Cedric RAM wäre schon erwähnt E3 gibt's seit 15 Uhr.
Jan AZ,
ist auch der wahrscheinlich am längsten existierende Newsletter zu nett politischen Themen in Europa LKW öffentlich oder monatlich rauskommt und sehr gute Nacht,
verschafft da drin was gerade auf EU Ebene diskutiert wird der ist sehr lang das ist so definitiv was für,
Liebhaber in aber man kann sich da auf jeden Fall rein Tigern und das ist eine gute Ressource um auf dem Laufenden zu bleiben.
Und wir sind nicht gezwungen alle Artikel jeder jeder 2 Wochen zu lesen.
Aber Dich gibt's keine Prüfungen das ist nicht irgendwer.
Die letzte Sache ist noch Ehre feiert in 15 jährigen Geburtstag glaube ich ja auch im April in Brüssel falls da jemand vorbeikommen will der wird es auf jeden Fall eine tolle Feier geben.
Und wenn wenn jemand etwas Gutes für digitale Bürgerrechte tun will heute dein schauen Sie nach,
Mitglieder von dem Juri Ausschuss im Europaparlament und rufen Sie ein paar.
Wahlamt deutsche Abgeordneten Umzug.
Zum Urheberrecht ja ja.
Guten finden wir den auch noch mal jo dann vielen Dank für die Zeit ich habe du musst ihr auch schon wieder los.
Ich hoffe das war ein guter Einblick mal in die praktische Arbeit im Bussler Büro und ja.
Aber ich ich glaube wir lassen das mal so stehen und schauen dass wir vielleicht öfter noch so Updates außer Robocop bekommen können das finde ich.
Ich auch und ich laufe jetzt zu einem Treffen zum Thema Daten kannst du Bescheid Zugang zu Beweismaterial.
Ja directive on cross-border everything that habe ich auch ausgesucht.
Gut viel Spaß noch.
Wischmann die ja dir auch vielen Dank bis dann tschüss so Thomas jetzt gibt's noch eine überraschende Meldung das Internet in Deutschland ist langsam.
Oh mein Gott wie konnte das passieren.
Das ist sehr eine shocking News ja die uns alle aus unserer wohlfeilen gesamt Gefühl dass auch alles super ist einfach so aufgeregt hat.
Da heißt es hier sage und schreibe 95,
5 % aller Telekom Kunden surfen mobil nur mit halber Geschwindigkeit auch bei anderen Anbietern sieht es nicht gut aus nicht einmal 2% bekommen,
ein Backofen der die 250 Grad erreicht nur jeder Fünfte bekommt ein Gerät das die 125° erzeugen kann,
kannst du es ein Zitat aus einem schönen Vergleich der bei netzpolitik.org gemacht wurde Bezug auf wie wäre denn das wenn WLAN Internetzugang ein Backofen wäre.
Antworten die Bandbreiten die so versichert werden und für die Manja sind letzten Endes endlich auch die Verträge abschließt werden halt überraschenderweise nicht durchgehend.
Reicht.
Uwe na ja also das ganze ist ein Artikel von Markus Reuter der bezieht sich auf den Jahresbericht,
Bundesnetzagentur zur breitbandmessung also die Bundesnetzagentur,
hat er ja ein Tool wo Konsumenten nachmessen können wie schnell ihr Internet wirklich ist und diese Daten werden jährlich eben in einem Report veröffentlicht und,
Ergebnisse sind halt wirklich desaströses also vor allem eben in ländlichen Gebiet ist es so,
dass die die die aller aller meisten Nutzer nicht die Bandbreiten bekommen für diese bezahlen und Karre in den Gebieten ist es ja auch so dass es kein Wettbewerb.
Dass man darauf kenne nur die Telekom als Anbieter hat und auch gar keine Wahlmöglichkeit würde man irgendwie aus diesem Vertrag raus freuen es ist nirgendwo besser.
Ahnte das ganze Thema.
Ist an sich mal irgendwie schlimm genug aber ich wollte eine Henry noch eine andere Dimension den dazu geben weil.
Wer meinen Tag auf dem 34 C3 zu zur Nettetal IT,
gehört hat weiß schon was kommt es gibt nämlich in Europa so eine Sonderregelung ich dass man dass man in der EU-Verordnung gesagt hat hier eigentlich kaufen Kunden ja nicht nur eine Internetleitung die bitteschön neutral sein soll oder nicht zwischen Applikation unterscheidet,
sondern ein die kaufen ja auch Internet in der Geschwindigkeit,
diese Geschwindigkeit soll bitte auch eingehalten werden und gerade im Fitness Bereich gibt's da eigentlich,
Richtung auf EU-Ebene das Internetanbieter nicht nur theoretisch bis zu Angaben machen wie schnell das Internet sein soll sondern auch Minimum Durchschnitts und maximum Band,
und die sollen dann eben auch,
Avene Supersport ist Durchschnitt kann man so definieren dass es mindestens bei weiß nicht 90% perzentil oder mindestens,
sonst so viel mal in so'n zuviel Messungen erreicht werden soll also da kann man sich ja Definitionen überlegen zuschicke.
Das auch am von der Bundesnetzagentur wie.
Bei den meisten Regulierungsbehörden was man aber in Deutschland verpasst hat ist der zweite Teil von so einem recht ist natürlich ja und wenn ich nicht als Kunde bekommt wofür ich zahl.
Dann muss ich eine Möglichkeit haben zu meinem Recht zu kommen und das wäre vor allem eben eine Tarif Minderung es gibt,
aber kann gerichtlich sich streiten dass man aus dem Vertrag raus kommt aber gerade eben an den Tischen Gebiet hilft an und das nichts,
weil man dann an der Stelle nichts anderes bekommt als das Recht nicht bei der Telekom zu sein und sonst gar kein Angebot zu haben aber vor allem eben wenn es darum geht eigentlich den Preis für.
Den Internetanschluss zu reduzieren gibt's da keine rechtliche Handhabe und da habe ich noch mal nachrecherchiert nachdem diese Meldung rauskam,
das wurde damals sogar bei der Reform des Telekommunikationsgesetzes in Deutschland 2016 ist gut,
aber das Wirtschaftsministerium hat sich damals quer gelegt und obwohl es dem Vernehmen nach sogar von Union seit,
ein grünes Licht gab das unten die einfach in welchen Regionen leben die schlechtes Internet bekommen schlechter als ihr Vertrag ist in den Zug,
die müssen nur noch weniger zahlen das heißt sie könnten ihre monatliche Pauschale reduzieren lassen und genau das wurde scheinbar vom Wirtschaftsministerium damals,
anzeigen das ist natürlich besonders kritisch zu sehen weil wir sind hier einfach ein Problem dass das Millionen von Haushalt betrifft und der Faktor sind die Nutzer alleine im Regen damit,
und haben derzeit leider überhaupt keine Handhabe dass er vielleicht etwas ist mein konditionsverhandlungen mal einbringen sollte.
Falls mal wieder welche gibt richtige.
Ich bin ein Freund von der Minderheitsregierung.
Aber du bist ja auch ein Netzneutralität Fundamentalist ja ich schätze mal du warst gemeint als Herr höcke ist der aktuelle Telekom Chef sich da jetzt gerade geäußert hat ich weiß nicht ob du das schon gesehen hast.
Nein habe ich nicht.
Ja also er hat ein paar interessante Feststellung überhaupt würde ja eigentlich viel zu viel reguliert werden in Europa wir sehen uns ja nicht genau andersrum,
und man muss ja eben mal eine umfassende die Regulierung machen damit die Telekom den nur so arbeiten könne wie sie wollte und das ganze.
Netzneutralität.
Argumentation Gebäude dass er ja alles blanker Unsinn warum man in eine email genauso schnell transportieren sollte wie eine Business-to-Business Anwendung das wäre alles ganz schlimm ist dir gegeben sowieso ganz kalt ist wenn ich dir die Feststellung dass,
für moderne Anwendungen oder kommt komischerweise ja immer noch irgendwie dieses Ding mit vernetzten Autos wo ja die irgendwie mit 5 kg dann ja wieder eine neue Zukunft haben soll theoretisch aber.
Weniger als zehn Millisekunden auf den Stationen vom Fahrzeug über die mobile site in die Cloud zu den Applikationen und wieder zurück sind viel zu viel Zitat Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist nicht genug.
Bitte deswegen bist Niclas jetzt ganz unten in die Infrastruktur eingebaut werden ist bisher die ganze Infrastruktur muss ja irgendwie überhaupt.
Mega intelligent werden und deswegen.
Ersatzmesser 13 Gramm einfach Unfug ich würde sagen Unfug ist ich weiß ja nicht so richtig wie die Telekom das hier,
plant hat sozusagen schneller als Lichtgeschwindigkeit die Daten anzuliefern das.
Farbfelder oder sowas oder.
Das Blatt noch das bleibt wirklich noch abzuwarten aber.
Ja dort ist es sehr sie müssen sich etwas überlegen lassen das mit dem Glasfaserausbau fällt hin auf den Kopf jetzt müssen sie irgendwie nein wir gehen schneller als Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Was man alles tun kann wenn wenn es einem nicht zu peinlich ist das der eigene Backbone so im Arsch ist wie bei der Telekom ich habe so ein Netz auf Verschleiß zu fahren und dann trotzdem.
Soll solche Forderungen zu stellen ja ich meine da dann.
Gibt's wirklich einen großen Teil der eigenen Kunden die man versteht die nicht das bekommen bevor Sie zahlen und anstelle dass man irgendwie den den Wettbewerb,
in Deutschland schon viel zu lange zählt gesetzlich mal irgendwie in diesem Markt presst versucht man einfach noch mehr neoliberalen Bullshit,
mit noch weniger Regulierung an dich weiter das Wetter jetzt die ganze Zeit mit 5g wiederholen ja das ist ja so viel Steuern und so viel Kontrolle gibt und dabei wird komplett übersehen.
Dass das was wirklich funktioniert das ist einfach nur Wettbewerben in Telekommunikationsmarkt,
drängen keine Diskriminierung zwischen Anbietern erlauben und gleichzeitig auch wirklich staatliche Gelder in die Hand nehmen um öffentliche Netze zu bauen und zwar Glasfasernetz,
dann von allen Betreibern genutzt werden kann.
Und was auch wahrscheinlich notwendig wäre im im im Mobilfunkbereich einfach auch das Viano modell zu erweitern weil da kann man schwer alternative Netze bauen aber da muss man einfach die bestehenden für andere Anbieter öffnen,
und zwar zu besseren Konditionen als das jetzt der Fall ist also,
ist streamen Blödsinn soll 1 und 1 einfach mal irgendwie so 30 GB oder gleich weg.
Tarife anbieten können ja ich meine es ist doch jetzt beliebt dass man um diese Preise mehr Volumen anbieten kann wirtschaftlich und dass das Netz dass das auch abkann.
Also das wäre auch wiederum das simple Lösung über Wettbewerb da da dient dem Bullshit einzufangen und all diese Beispiele die jetzt hier genannt werden also lokale clouds mit schneller als Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Die soll mal wirklich offen darlegen ja das sind die Dienste die wir uns vorstellen nicht irgendwelche illusorischen.
Business gefahren Sachen sondern das sind konkret die Produkte die Via Spezialdienste haben wollen da kann man sich darüber unterhalten,
wird man sehen ob das im Rahmen der europäischen Vorgaben machbar ist oder nicht es gibt die Möglichkeit von Spezial Diensten wenn die die Anforderungen erfüllen,
aber so die ganze Zeit über die Hintertür das ist,
ja eigentlich nur dafür da um um um um die Debatte zu versauen und weg von den Fakten zu kommen so wie damals Wertinger irgendwas mit selbstfahrenden Autos an dieser Stelle.
Sprache der fachlichen Debatte nicht zuträglich.
Nee das ist wirklich hanebüchen dass ihr mich mit diesem Ding also meine ich will einfach keinen autonomes Auto was davon abhängig ist das irgendeine Cloud sich rechtzeitig meldet also das wird sich ja sowieso nicht durchsetzen dieses also dieses,
technische Prinzip dieser Ansatz kann ich mir einfach nicht vorstellen entweder die Dinger in der Lage alles lokal zu entscheiden und nur da,
kann man überhaupt davon ausgehen dass das die Netze sozusagen auch wie soll ich sagen also man muss ich davon ausgehen dass die Netze auch da sind.
Wann brauchst du denn einfach nicht das ist schön wenn wenn sie da sind aber es muss natürlich auf jeden Fall auch funktioniert wenn man einen Netzzugang ausfällt oder nicht erreichbar ist Lichtgeschwindigkeit hin und her ich denke für Deutschland würde Lichtgeschwindigkeit eigentlich vollkommen ausreichen.
Wer sollte man vielleicht langsam mal annähernd so.
An der Stelle fängt mir noch mal es gibt ein schönes Video das Wetter muss zu retten hast Seiten gemacht haben Netzwerk alität,
tötet da wird sogar dieser Mythos mit den selbstfahrenden Autos aufgegriffen und dass das halt in in ml jeden Tunnel und jeder Bergregion schon bricht dieses Dogma dass man da immer Netzanschluss bräuchte und Kessler ist ja auch das beste Beispiel wie sind der Prag,
kann also dass das mein Weg,
nur solche Argumente verwendet da da braucht man ja auch ordentlich taube Ohren auf die solcher Bullshit stoßen muss damit man da nicht sofort ausgelacht wird,
dass das finde ich so bezeichnet dass man an der Stelle einfach sie ist sie sich nur noch obskuren Meinungen mit uns Kundenmeinungen beschäftigt und gerade eben so dieser Telekommunikationsbereich in Deutschland.
Bisschen auf russisch.
Genau also Deutschland ist alles hoffnungslos wie finden in Österreich.
Ja wir haben ja ein Regierung eine eine schwarz-blaue also,
Kondratieff Rechtsaußen und die haben jetzt im Jänner ihr erstes netzpolitisches Gesetz vorgeschlagen und zwar geht's darum einen,
Anpassungsgesetz Inneres das kommt aus dem Innenministerium und da werden Änderungen gemacht in allen möglichen Gesetzen um,
Schutz Richtlinie umzusetzen es gibt ja die datenschutz-grundverordnung die Minecraft dritt,
ja gibt's auch eine Richtlinie die sich um den polizeilichen Bereich kümmert und,
die wurde da eben umgesetzt ist es sind noch ein paar andere Anpassungen dabei aber das ist grundsätzlich worum es dabei geht und epicenter works hat sich die mal angeschaut und es klappt auch schon von mehreren Parlaments,
deine Stellungnahme dazu das mit diesem Gesetz eben die Protokoll Pflichten eingeschränkt werden,
Zeit nämlich auf eine sehr lustige Art und Weise also eigentlich im Moment ist es so in Österreich jedesmal wenn ein Polizist auf Daten zugreift dann muss man das 3 Jahre protokollieren.
Er fragt Daten von.
Personen ab aus in welchen Datenbanken dem vergiss um Datenbanken des sichert polizeilichen Bereichs also durchaus welche mit sehr kritischen inhalt wo es auch dann so um.
Gefährder Sport,
Banco Stadionbesuche drinnen sind und solche Sachen und hier protokolliert man natürlich wie das so üblich ist davor jetzt zu dem Zeitpunkt auf den Datensatz zugegriffen mit dieser Rechtsgrundlage und von dieser Person.
Und genau.
Der letzte Teil wird weg gestrichen bei automatischen abfragen wird eben nicht mehr protokolliert welche Person auf dieser Daten zugegriffen hat.
Und die protokollpflicht wird von 3 auf 2 Jahre reduziert mit deiner schöne Begründung Speicher minimieren.
Ach so die Plattenplatz ist zu knapp.
Genau bitte dir dieser Terabyte Platten sind zu teuer.
Da kann man ja sicher noch nach danach den Namen drauf schreiben von den Leuten die für Datenzugriff gemacht aber bitte Zugriff als solcher wird schon protokolliert.
Genau aber dann eben bei automatischen abfragen und da ändert sich scheinbar auch was weil automatisch war früher eine wo eine Abfrage die automatisch passiert ist eine ohne Willensbekundung kann man sich jetzt vorstellen irgendein Kennzeichen Erfassungsgerät.
Da muss ich jetzt nicht wissen welches Gerät das war.
Weiß schon hilfreich ist weil das ist ja im Zweifelsfalle Beweiskette gleichzeitig wenn ich deine Fahndung nach einem Kennzeichen auf dem AB will ich vielleicht wissen wer den Treffer bei,
das da Karten Auto vorbeigefahren ist also auch in solchen Fällen wäre es sinnvoll aber automatisch ist da die nicht konkret definiert die Definition könnte sich sogar ändern mit,
neuen Datenschutzgesetz es ist ein kleiner Luxus und ich wollte halt einen weißen aktive Debatte gibt und,
bis zum 8. Februar die Möglichkeit sich mit einer Stellungnahme bei diesem Gesetz sofort zu melden wir verlinken die relevanten Dokumente.
Achja stell mir gerade vor wie so ein schönsten oberösterreichischer wie die Anfrage abgelehnt wird mit Wasser kann ich was sie wollen hier steht doch wer den Zugriff gemacht hat Automat.
Online Auto Automat.
Bis jetzt extra Punkte dafür kriegen dass ich nicht erst versucht habe.
Da sind wir beide scheitern.
An ja.
Also dann tut sich auch ein bisschen was ansonsten ich will garnicht mehr über die österreichische Innenpolitik sprechen das ist nur traurig.
Aber ja ich glaube wir haben die in das Logbuch die Logbuch Verpflichtung einigermaßen abgehandelt.
Und sei mal schauen ob es noch schaffen die Sendung zu machen bevor die Nuss wiederkommt.
Du bist Monstern beeilen weil irgendwann in der nächsten Woche wird er sich dann mal wieder zurück melden sind jetzt beide viel auf Reisen von David zeigen wir schauen mal was so funktioniert.
Wu-Tang mache den Sack zu für diese Woche.
Ja es hat mich sehr gefreut irgendwie hier ein Stelldichein Ersatzmann zu sein hier im Podcast,
A&A ja nur doch mal die Kommentare und Battle Feedback zu geben das wird mich interessieren vor allem auch wir haben ja doch thematisch und bissl den Fokus verschoben,
am und auch auch diesbezüglich willst mich interessieren ob das hätten wir schon zuviel Europa wahr oder sprachlich wird wir haben uns auch überlegt ob wir jetzt bei dortmund.de gemerkt ihn auf Englisch oder auf Deutsch sprechen des.
Du kannst zum Glück sehr passabel Deutsch aber natürlich gibt es englischsprachige Gäste auch noch viel,
mehr an das wird nicht einfach interessieren ob da starke Präferenzen der höheren Schaft.
Genau Urlaub mach mal was auf Englisch werfen sollte aber ist halt immer so eine Sache wenn man irgendwie.
Programm auf Deutsch macht dann.
Ist heute mal den Strom soweit es eben geht auch so aufrecht erhalten das sicherlich im Einzelfall meiner Oma anders entscheiden nun gut.
Dann denke ich mal, dass erstmal ihr da draußen vielen Dank fürs Zuhören wir hören uns bald wieder Tschüss bis bald.
Ciao.